new delhi véritable ville fantôme la
capitale indienne est confinée depuis
lundi dernier et le sera une semaine de
plus suite à la prolongation du
confinement décidées par le gouvernement
il faut dire que l'inde n'est pas
épargné par le cos vie de 19 17 millions
de cas dont près d'un million sur les
trois derniers jours le pays compte
également près de 200000 morts depuis le
début de la pandémie soit le deuxième
pays le plus touché au monde hôpitaux
bondés
la capitale est en manque de réserves
d'oxygène et de lits une situation
intenable pour la population je suis
allée dont presque tous les hôpitaux de
ghaziabad tous m'ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'oxygène
je me suis donc rendu à l'hôpital rajiv
gandhi où l'on nous a chassés même de
l'entrée en disant qu'il n'avait pas
d'oxygène
puis nous sommes arrivés ici et il a été
testé pour le coronavirus mais ils n'ont
même pas prescrit de médicaments pour
lui je ne parviens pas à comprendre ce
que je dois faire je ne vois pas de
solution que puis-je faire je n'ai rien
mangé ni bu depuis ce matin tu n'es fait
qu'essuyer rejet sur rejet cette
situation est due à un triple mutants
indien plus contagieux ce mutant fait
des ravages dans tout le pays et semble
hors de contrôle au point que l'inde en
est venu à demander de l'aide extérieure
l'union européenne a répondu à cet appel
par le biais d'ursula von der leyen
le mécanisme européen de protection
civile va être activé et permettra aux
états membres de coordonner leur aide et
de déployer des moyens dans le monde
entier en cas d'urgence alarmés par la
situation épidémiologique en inde
nous sommes prêts à soutenir l'union
européenne met en commun ses ressources
pour répondre rapidement à la demande
d'assistance de l'inde via le mécanisme
de protection civile de l'union
européenne nous sommes en pleine
solidarité avec le peuple indien
des propos qui font écho à ceux d'angela
merkel la chancelière allemande a
annoncé ce dimanche que son gouvernement
se prépare à fournir une aide d'urgence
à l'inde
les etats unis ont également répondu
présents en annonçant qu'ils déploieront
des moyens pour venir en aide au
gouvernement et aux aides soignants
indien
les etats unis ont identifié la
provenance d'ingrédients spécifiques
nécessaires à la production en inde de
vac sens antique au vide qui vont être
immédiatement fourni à l'inde une aide
mondiale nécessaire pour le quatrième
pays le plus meurtri par le cos vite 19